[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
pour le 11e déjeuner de lives in
business club et nous avons l'immense
plaisir de recevoir pas de fric dutartre
général d'aviation et ancien leader de
la patrouille de france patrick
bienvenus oui merci françois avère très
heureux d'abord être accueillis ici dans
cet endroit somptueux parce que c'est le
globe de la boule y est
le business club c'est une recette qui
était créé à lille il ya quelques années
j'ai eu la chance de participer à ses
débuts et c'était très beau lieu une
très belle manière en fait très belle
opportunité pour des gens de croiser
expérience et de rencontrer des experts
dans différents métiers et aujourd'hui
donc c'est de faire et essayer de faire
un parallèle assez amusant d'ailleurs
entre une patrouille acrobatique un peu
emblématiques comme la patrouille de
france et le fonctionnement quotidien
d'une entreprise au travers de la
performance des équipes et donc il ya
des parlait beaucoup plus intéressant
que de gens peuvent imaginer
et donc c'est le sujet aujourd'hui
d'actualité
et donc je mente d'accueillir avec toi
aux applaudissements patrick dutartre
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment nous avoir rejoints tu
connais les business club tu connais
l'esprit et je crois que tu adhères
aussi aux valeurs
qu'est ce que tu veux nous proposer
aujourd'hui comme programme le lien
entre quel est le lien entre la
patrouille de france
les entreprises comment tu vois ça et
bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci de
m'accueillir ici d'endroits qu'elle est
magnifique dans ce coin est alors déjà
vous avez une proximité puisque vous
savez que juste derrière vous avez la
base aérienne de villacoublay qui est à
la fois une base de l'armée de l'air
mais également une base gouvernementale
chaque fois qu'un otage se pose quelque
part c'est ici en fait pourquoi parce
que sa proximité avec l'elysée et avec
le ministère des affaires étrangères
alors quel rapport entre une patrouille
acrobatique mais la patrouille de france
et l'entreprise va vous allez voir on va
regarder quelques images et puis en
apparence il ya aucun rapport entre des
avions qui volent à 850 km heure à trois
mètres cinquante les uns des autres et
pourtant vous allez voir que tout à
l'heure que pour qu'on fonctionne comme
ça on est obligées d'appliquer des
principes des concepts et on utilise des
outils t extrêmement pratique et ses
outils en fait vous pouvez les utiliser
chacun d'entre vous dans vos entreprises
au quotidien c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui s'est transposée tous ces
principes dans les entreprises tout cas
c'est très alléchant alors une autre
dimension c'est vraiment une dimension
centrée sur l'homme et l'humain et donc
je te propose de rapidement faire un
survol de ton parcours
donc on voit là des personnes bien
rangée l'école de l'air de salon de
provence
quelques années auparavant est ce que tu
peux nous décrire ton ton parcours qui
est qu est ce qui a guidé sa non mais en
fait moi c'est un peu par hasard j'ai
débarqué dans cette très belle école qui
est l'école des officiers de l'armée de
l'air à salon
d'ailleurs notre parrain promotion
c'était à l'époque chirac qui était
premier ministre il lui de passer quand
je lui dis ça quelques années après il
dira je très content mon colonel
très fier de votre part et oui en fait
ma ma chère maman me disait un jour
quand j'étais en terminale
quel métier tu veux faire j'ai dit mais
il faut déjà décidé si tôt et me dit oui
parce qu'il va falloir faire des études
et donc j'y réfléchis un peu mais en
fait je voudrais faire un métier sportif
et intellectuels ça que ma guide est ce
que vous avez une maman labaki à son
fils entre lehmann et d'écoles de l'air
et donc voilà je pouvais pas être mieux
servi que par et donc j'ai du coup j'ai
dit hier je rêvais de pilotes et les
machines maman me dit pour être pilote
faut d'abord faire peut-être militaire
ce qui était vrai à ceux de la guerre
mais qui était plus du tout vrai avant
l'époque et finalement j'ai découvert
l'armée de l'air comme ça et j'ai
beaucoup aimé je l'adorais d'ailleurs
j'ai même presque plus de plaisir avec
la famille armée de l'air qu'avec le
pilotage ainsi le pilotage évidemment
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
voilà comment j'ai débarqué à l'école et
ensuite je suis un parcours de chasse
pour les années alors avant donc
parcours international aussi oui mais
après que vous faites une carrière
opérationnelle pendant 15 ans 20 ans ou
fait ce qu'on appelle l'école de guerre
donc je fais l'école de guerre à paris à
l'école militaire en un terrain mais oui
ça c'est une école de guerre pour l'otan
en fait et donc tous les pays le temps
envoyé quelques personnes pour faire des
études
l'international dans le cas des
engagements que l'on a dans le monde
entier en fait ce que je propose c'est
que nous mettions dans l'ambiance
donc je propose est attaché ceinture
parce que doit décoller
on prend 40 et amusant
l'intérieur
omar
[Musique]
wang
bon
[Musique]
également la place
ok impeccable
patrick qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque ces
images quand tu lui as eu de voix n'ont
rien de particulier si ce n'est qu' un
détail non c'est juste montrer que la
base de fonds ne fait pas que le 14
juillet elle fait également des
présentations en vol
quand on voit pas souvent en région
parisienne sauf si on va à la ferté
alais à pentecôte ou hamelin ont fait
des meetings aériens et donc ces
quelques images vues de l'intérieur de
ces meetings en fait or justement ce
slide le montre bien là on n'est pas
vraiment au dessus de paris
oui lesquelles représentent la
patrouille de france à l'international
où l annexion image en fait c'est
amusant parce que se trouve que j'étais
j'étais là j'étais charognards numéro
deux en fait juste derrière le leader en
c'était comment 786 effectivement
s'avérer un rôle diplomatique important
parce que souvenez vous c'était l'année
où les américains ont bombardé la libye
kadhafi suite l'instant pas de lockerbie
ou on soupçonnait que c'était des
libyens qui étaient responsables cette
atteinte a du coup les américains fn
d'ultimatum aux libyens et avaient
bombardé kadhafi il veut tout une
polémique sur le fait que la france
aurait empêché les américains du survol
du territoire français et donc le fait
d'aller quelque temps ce qui était faux
d'ailleurs quelques temps plus on est
allé aux états unis et c'est la première
fois de l'histoire et donc on a eu
beaucoup de retentissement parce que
c'est en même temps le centenaire de
l'indépendance d'un centenaire pendant
de la statue de liberté et donc les
bicentenaires l'indépendance et en 86 et
donc en effet trois meetings le premier
jour 350 mille personnes deuxième jour
750 milles et troisième jours un million
cinq sur coney island donc c'est assez
sympa on va fait un mois aux etats unis
c'était un rôle diplomatique en fait
alors donc là tu tues tu tu ne parles de
la patrouille en disant bon oui souhaite
pas grand chose des souvenirs salaires
anecdotique mais ça l'est absolument pas
quels sont les critères pour pouvoir
rejoindre une équipe aussi prestigieuse
non en fait c'est un peu de chance la
patrouille de france c'est bien sûr des
pilotes de chasse de l'armée de l'air
donc fait une carrière standard de
pilote de chasse qui dure à peu près dix
ans au d'échelle de patrouille confirmé
je sais pas s'il y en a qui pilote ici
j'ai piloté un super combien de vols oui
mais c'est très bien combien super donc
d'être le spécialiste aéronautique civil
liberties union prenait tellement on a
un pilote d'hélicoptère mais il eut pas
là egolf ailleurs fait je passe sous son
contrôle en fait tout le monde paie
pilotes 1 la preuve est également un
épisode de chat je vous assure si vous
avez les yeux est la colonne vertébrale
la seule problématique en fait pour nous
ça va de la vitesse d'apprentissage est
en fait tous les jours en fait on va
être noté on a défini avec l'expérience
une courbe idéal d'apprentissage et 7
pour un peu de chasse était à peu près
sept ans pour devenir chef de patrouille
et tous les jours d'être noté l'acca de
couleur bleu vert jaune rouge bleu
faisaient tout de suite la couleur en
tissage vers vous êtes sur la colossale
jaune vous êtes en dessous et rouge
c'est carton rouge celle à ses côtés des
vols longue date et donc faire ma
carrière frotter dans le bleu le vert ça
dure presse cette température de
patrouille trois ans et demi pour être
pilote opérationnel et quand vous avez 3
ans d'expérience de chez de patrouille
dont peu près dix ans dans l'armée de
l'air vous pouvez candide et à la
patrouille de france et
et là en fait tous les ans il ya trois
places qui se libèrent au cerveau devant
partir et on change d'heure deux anciens
s'en vont il ya trois nouveaux qui
intègre alors qu'elles sont des critères
qu'on va retenir il y en a trois d'abord
c'est le seul endroit
ce n'était l'armée de l'air on va on va
faire ce qu'on appelle la cooptation
cotation ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que c'est la patrouille en place qui va
décider parmi les candidats ils sont
tous des volontaires
mais le chef d'état major de l'armée de
l'air ce interdit d'imposer un pilote à
patrouille c'est uniquement les pilotes
en place qui vont choisir les trois
nouveaux elle est recrutée sur trois
principaux critères le premier c'est la
formation vient de vous indiquer chef de
patrouille confirmé sur mirage 2000 ou
rafale donc avec dix ans pilotage de
près 1800 vol à leur actif
le deuxième critère c'est leur
eréputation et le troisième critère qui
vous concerne vous directement quand
vous introduisez quelqu'un dans vos
équipes
pour nous c'est de mesurer l'aptitude
d'un nouvel arrivant a oublié sa
performance individuelle pour se mettre
au service du collectif performant
strictement individuel chez nous
évidemment n'a aucun sens ce n'est pas
au service du collectif
alors comment ce qu'on va mesurer sa
baisse est tout simplement le
comportement
le savoir est de l'individu et pour nous
il ne savait même pas les candidats et
c'est le principal critère pour retenir
un nouvel arrivant pourquoi parce que
vous le savez bien
observez bien chez vous dans vos équipes
une seule personne peut mettre une
gargouille pas possible il ne peut pas
se permettre c'est pour ça qu'on est
extrêmement vigilants sur le
comportement en fait donc l'aptitude de
se se mettre au service du collectif
de ce slide et là on débute un chapitre
qui qui a plusieurs feuillets je dirais
donc la performance collective donc
comment toi tu laves apercevait tu la
mesure est puisque alors tu parles de
comportement comment on peut le traduire
de manière factuelle alors la première
chose qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand
vous débarquez la patrouille fait un
premier vol en place arrière
pourquoi fait en classe arrière pourtant
qu'aussi bien le fad je vous ai fait
vous étaient 150 heures de vol moins sur
cet avion en place avant mais le
problème c'est que vous êtes incapable
de voler une 5 secondes avec la
patrouille
c'est même pire que ça on vous installe
derrière on doit 10 pour ce premier vol
tu vas être en place arrière surtout tu
ne touche à rien
le vol dure une petite heure l issue du
vol au sol en fera un débriefing vous
observer et à l'issue du vol ce qui est
très amusant observer c'est que tous je
dis bien tous les nouveaux pilotes
affectés à la patrouille depuis plus de
65 ans
à l'issue de ce premier vol en place
arrière ont exactement les trois mêmes
actions qui à votre avis son excellence
à celles à deux
alors si pire que ça c'est la peur de
pas y arriver c'est la deuxième raison
la première raison ils sont complètement
fous ces mecs
la troisième raison c'était super sympa
quand elle soit commence alors pour
qu'ils sont fous bien sûr en raison de
la proximité et le risque de collision
en vol à mettre 50
oui c'est ça qui va contre les
bouteilles
ouais ouais ouais ça s'apprend oui alors
pourquoi ils sont fous alors évidemment
c'est le risque de collision en vol
figurez vous que ces statistiques
l'expérience monde connaît au nautic la
collision en vol se passe rarement bien
c'est un constat pour tout petits on
vous apprend à maîtriser votre
trajectoire et éviter un obstacle en vol
et éviter une trajectoire conflictuelles
avec un autre avion
mais là là comme on est à trois mètres
cinquante les uns des autres en moyenne
parce que vous fondez plus près au début
c'était vraiment drôle quand et en plus
quand on fait de la patrouille serré ce
qu'on a appris en aviation de chasse ou
en hélico vous n'avez pas le droit de
dépasser 60 degrés d'inclinaison les
palois dépasser 2 j'ai fait bien sûr
aucune figure de voltige et là c'est
tout le contraire en fait des figures de
voltige vous dépassez bien sûr dauger
dsk 3g 4g et 5g qui sont un tout virage
instantané et puis on est à trois mètres
et puis et puis on n'est pas deux avions
ont mené huit avions et donc c'est ça
qui fait peur un peu au début quand même
et puis quand vous êtes charognards au
début ça vous fait quand même drôle
d'avoir les sept autres tout autour de
vous donc sa première raison pour
laquelle ça fait peur la seconde raison
pour laquelle ça fait peur ce sont les
rassemblements comment est-ce qu'on
rassemble un avion dans le ciel
donc si françois émond leader par
exemple tu regardes bien alors tu vois
tu le sais bien la caméra d'accord quand
vous êtes équipiers
quand vous êtes pilote opérationnel vous
lever intercepté un chasseur mais d'état
dans un coin de ciel
françois la bassée votre dossier de
l'avion intercepté vous foncer sur lui
mon tour as-tu peur aussi d'un maître
s'il te plaît ahmed est là pour dix
mille altesse de rapprochement qu'est ce
que vous faites vous allez vous allez
ouvrir et venir chercher une trajectoire
d'interception pour vous arrêter à peu
près 1000 mètres derrière derrière
l'avion a intercepté contrôler ces
paramètres de vol puis tout doucement
vous et venir en patrouille comme ça
donc ça vous imaginez bien que ça prend
un certain temps c'est la méthode
normale pour assembler sur un avion tu
peux rester pendant la semaine
mais la patrouille quand on éclate six
ou huit avions dans tous les coins du
ciel si on fait cette méthode qui prend
une minute une minute trente deux
minutes pour assembler ça m'a pas
terrible on va vous apprendre à faire
quelque chose qui est strictement
interdite
quelque chose que si vous aviez l'avait
fait une seule fois dans les 10 années
de formation vous auriez été arrêtés
deux vols carton rouge
qu'est ce que vous faites est là
équipiers de la patrouille
vous devez rassemblés sur françois vous
fait pas le tour comme ça c'est beaucoup
trop long
vous faites la chose suivante tu peux te
concentrer cet organe savais que ça dure
vous partez en cas de collision sur le
paquet et au dernier moment on fait un
super dérapage en ciel et vous arrêtez
je la refais pour second poteau compris
on parle en cas de collision et au denim
enfin super dérapages comme en ski et on
s'arrête saint-françois s'agit là tu
veux regarder ça fait très très peur
déjà là j'ai un peu peur j'imagine la
roue et le ski ça me parle à la fois
pour celui qui le fait également à la
fois pour les copains qui voit l'autre
arriver et donc c'est ça qu'on va
essayer de faire apprendre aux jeunes
comment comment est ce qu'on va leur
faire surmonter leurs peurs comment on
va le rendre possible sur semble
impossible c'est le premier challenge
et puis les autres challenges c'est que
tous les ans on change de leader leader
s'en va il continue armée de l'air moi
j'ai comme responsable escales de chasse
après tout ça on a deux ans 500 vont et
donc trois nouveaux intégrés et puis
tous les ans tout le monde change de
place et tous les ans en fin de
spectacle et c'est ça qui est
intéressant
tutu restait deux ans toi leaders rouges
et un an maintenant charognards dans le
leader en fait d'accord et c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est que compte tenu de
tous ces changements chaque année qui
sont un peu imposée du fait que la
patrouille de france est une mission
annexe ii en valait 1 banques attendent
over important l'état major patrick de
traces trop longtemps dans cette mission
est ça qui est intéressant pour vous on
a dû mettre on n'a plus le choix
on a dû mettre en place des process
de fonctionnement qui doivent nous
permettre une certaine excellence
opérationnelle tous les ans quelle que
soit l'individu et sont justement ces
process qui sont intéressants que je
vous montrerai tout à l'heure le point
important dans la mission collective
chacun a une place très a signé donc là
des numéros si joannie genuine année par
exemple si c'est comment votre prénom
pied henry si vous êtes extérieur gauche
pour la saison d'hiver qui est en ce
moment entre le 15 novembre et le 1er
mai vous apprenez votre boulot vous êtes
numéro 5 extérieur gauche
et puis à partir du 1er mai jusqu'au 15
octobre
quelle saison meeting vous êtes toujours
numéro 5 mais tous les ans je vais
changer de place
l'énoncé charognards ça vient d'où ça
lui si la charnière personne ne sait
vraiment mais il ya quand même c'est le
charnière c'est le cas tout au mieux on
fait quatre bonnes raisons le premier
raison c'est que les tours dans les
fumigènes du leader la seconde raison
c'est parce que c'est le futur leader
lui être calife à la place du calife
donc on a tous dans nos entreprises un
charognard observez bien parfois
plusieurs y en a plusieurs tours et la
troisième raison c'est parce que pour
ceux qui ont fait leur service militaire
dans l'armée de l'air mais je sais pas
si on a beaucoup
l'inca péri ce militaire l'armée de
l'air par sa villa à côté on a tous dans
les armées une arme de reconnaissance
enfin dans tout art bien un signe de
reconnaissance et l'insigne pour
lamellaire c'est un oiseau
cet oiseau c'est un épervier charognards
sont là pour qu'on appelle le 3 le catch
horner est traditionnement les leaders
passent toujours sa première année en
charnière comme ce qu'il est au milieu
du paquet et se permet de bien observer
ce qui se passe
tout à l'heure on a eu le plaisir
d'avoir la présentation de michel qui
fait des corps dont on entendait c'est
pour ça que les images sont légèrement
ancien que nous avons vu de talent mais
je pense qu'ils sont très significatives
on entend une communication très syncopé
avec des coupures
comment comment ça se passait est-ce que
ça c'est une difficulté comment se passe
la communication entre pilotes alors
déjà je pense le contrôle de notre
spécialiste aéronautique en aéronautique
on raconte pas sa vie en fait un ce que
tout - sa fréquence donc on extrêmement
le concis mais surtout tout se fait au
départ de la préparation en fait et ce
qu'on voit tout à l'heure c'est que j'ai
passées vous savez en aéronautique
tout le monde utilise le mot briefing
par exemple l'entreprise maintenant mais
beaucoup ont oublié que mon briefing
bien l'aéronautique
dès 1914 l'épisode partait aux avions à
l'époque n'est pas de radio pour
communiquer entre eux qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient
préparez soigneusement l'ambition puis
on les réussit dans une salle comme ça
et le comment escadrille où le chef des
missions faisait à briefing de
coordination les pilotes effectuent l
envol en mission et puis à l'issue du
vol retour on faisait un débris fait
savoir qu'un érotique briefing
débriefing sont une religion impensable
de partir en vol sans un briefing à mon
vol est un débriefing après vol que vous
soyez en a380 en cessna en n'importe
quel avion que son parachute ont fait au
moins chanceux auront la patrouille de
france ou en rafale on fait toujours un
briefing et en vol il ya l'issue du vol
on fera un débriefing ça c'est la
première chose pour chacun sache
exactement ce qu'il a à faire et qui a
absolument aucun malentendu dans
l'équipe et aussi une astuce pour
augmenter la communication d'astuces
génial extrêmement peu d'entreprises ici
font peut-être même personne passionnée
une poing levé la main parce que c'est
tellement rare michelin fait ça
décathlon faisait sa une banque qui fait
ça il ya très très peu d'entreprises
en aéronautique ont un langage commun
quand par exemple vous n'arrêtez au
prénom ce qu'il faut 3 pierre henry
quand pierre henry est à new york avec
son a380 mis en route son avion fait
plein de carburant les bagages les
passagers tout le monde est là il
l'autorisation de la tour de contrôle de
mettre en route y roule et un moment il
va rouler sur ce qu'on appelle des
taxiways et va s'arrêter juste à côté de
la piste et là avant de décoller qu'est
ce qu'il fait excellent et après
et demandent l'autorisation à la tour de
contrôle et qu'est-ce qui lui dit
canet dit césar france ou six nine west
line up est là que lui répondent à tour
de contrôle la ceast organisé trois
réponses possibles
première réponse à la fois résistant à
des standby colliers bagues ou air
france ou six niner line up and white ou
line up cleantech off qui est très
intéressant d'observer c'est que
pierre-henri poser mille questions
moscou la une à peine 8 à tokyo
ce qui veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
a défini un langage commun
ça veut dire qu'à tous les points clés
il ya des mots obligatoire qui sont
extrêmement précis etc avec une
définition en face pourquoi est ce qu on
fait ça pour éviter les malentendus dans
les équipes pour éviter des malentendus
entre les pilotes et les contrôleurs
c'est un langage qui définit par loi si
tous les pilotes du monde tous les
colonnes du monde je suis exactement les
mêmes mots et ces mots sont définis un
catalogue qui ici dit ça dans son
entreprise
c'est simple c'est les 35 assabah
excellent bravo monsieur sait comment
votre nom des bus est ce qu'on gagne en
clarté et c'est phénoménal c'est facile
à faire les 35 à 50 mots que vous
utilisez plus souvent même dans
n'importe quel secteur d'activité pour
que les nouveaux arrivants même que les
anciens n'est pas de malentendu sur un
monde
pas savoir ce qu'on gagne en clarté
c'est très facile à faire certaines
choses que je fais quand j'accompagne
d'entreprise c'est le langage commun et
puis je retiens un point ici a mentionné
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on raconte pas
sa vie non ça c'est important aussi été
un peu de mots clairs trois secondes à
un langage au départ et puis ensuite en
vol après on est strictement factuel des
mots très très précis ce qui n'empêche
pas de parfois de plaisanter en vol
aussi mais il faut un peu d'expérience
pour présenter parce qu'il faut bien
être et santé
alors si on reprend donc je suis pas sûr
d'être tout de suite prête pour être le
leader c'est ce que je peux mettre un
peu plus avant le mans alors là on est à
trois mètres cinquante comment on fait
pour pas ce que tu dis tu disais ça de
manière très simple on à 850 km heure on
est deux fois moins de 3 mètres 50
oui mais comment on fait pour garder
cette existence parce que l'on a des
repères et bouge pas bon est ce que tu
peux tendre la main
laquelle gauche est ce que tu peux
attendre vers moi excellent les à
l'horizontale comme celle de la nature
notamment comme ça au clair en position
avions très bien
voilà un excellent premier repère c'est
qu'on aligne le casque du leader sur le
saumon de l'elsasser le bout de la maca
ça donne un premier repère dans le ciel
donc tu peux t'en aussi en cours de 20
cm sont tombées très bien donc je
m'aligne sur sept est la scène de notre
ami robert le second repère je vais
prendre ces derniers les deux réacteurs
derrière si vous êtes trop arrière
voyait les deux réacteurs ouvert si vous
êtes trop avant ici vous voyez juste un
angle de réacteurs donc ça ça vous donne
la notion de retrait le troisième
repères qu'on va se mettre c'est donc
dans le même plan des ailes c'est à dire
que et quand vous regardez bien avec ses
trois repères ça vous donne un point
idéal ici et là que vous ne donnez
jamais parfaitement en fait c'est
toujours en train de tourner autour et
donc en fait on ne quitte pas de vue son
leader et en creux tchèque en permanent
fin la viande à côté de soi et on compte
chèques en permanence et trois repères
on a calculé pour avoir un tir de
seconde d'inattention
on est on est scotché en train de
tourner obtenu que lé leader sauf quand
on s'écarte un peu en paix il ya deux
ans mais sinon donc on fait confiance
aveugle au leader d'où la responsabilité
pour les deux la donne de sérieuses
perspectives dans les entreprises alors
aux communications entre pilotes
nous l'avons vu alors pardon je sais moi
qui vais en arrière c'est bien des fois
de prendre du temps pour avancer mieux
mais on va avancer vraiment alors là tu
lui as tu m'avais passé hier un slide
sur une vision la conduite du changement
tube rehab est ce que je vous ai tout à
l'heure c'est que tous les ans donc en
champs de leader les anciens s'en vont
en trois nouveaux équipiers changement
de plateau mais plantation c'est à dire
quoi c'est qu'on avait fallu mettre en
place ces process c'est sur ces process
qui sont intéressants le qu'on verra
peut-être tout à l'heure je sais pas si
on voit juste après voilà en fait on a
trois grands principes en fait en effet
une étude on a trouvé douze principes 12
process qui sont indispensables
patrouille acrobatique regarder les
sélections intégration place émissions
de chaque information préparation
briefing lisation débriefing
transmission des savoir-faire cohésion
d'équipé motivation leadership et en
fait on a fait trois constats relisez
tranquillement ses douze paramètres et
qu'est ce que vous observez pour une
patte le premier constat pour une
patrouille acrobatique
il vaut mieux être bon dans l'es12
observez bien normalement ça doit
marcher assez bien dans les 12 premiers
constats deuxième constat ça c'est
intéressant est ce qu'on peut se passer
d'un seul des douze
observez bien mais que c'est pas facile
de se passer d'un seul des douze et le
troisième constat dans ses douze
thématiques combien sont relatives à
toute équipe dans toute entreprise
c'est ce que vous faites vous relever
ces 12es vous faites un questionnaire et
vos collaborateurs en revenant tout à
l'heure et vouloir dit qu'elles notent
tu nous mets de un à dix ans et tout ce
paramètre ça vous donne un excellent
thermomètre du niveau de performance de
l'équipe instantané le but c'est d'avoir
dix sur dix qui est presque impossible
même chez nous mais on peut y entendre
et ce qui est intéressant c'est de pas
avoir de trou surtout que je propose un
oui transfert pour ceux qui seront
intéressés par la présentation jeu
mettra à disposition
alors dans la préparation j'avais
discuté à caroline qui est tous là bas
et dans un déjeuner précédent et
caroline me posais une question c'est
que l'avait une certaine obsession de
l'excellence et je propose que là on
pose cette question c'est à dire que là
on voit tu disais 10 sur 10 c'est mieux
mais bon comment on fait le dire elle le
day 2 du disque dur disent tout le temps
puisque tu cette heure-là position on la
tient jamais parfaitement que comment on
fait cette appréciation de la volonté
d'excellence à tout prix qui parfois
peut nuire même à aux bons résultats
non mais en fait mais nous c'est jamais
plus c'est d'abord si jamais parfait
chez nous c'est jamais parfait mais ça
ne m'empêche pas d'y travailler en fait
ça me dire la permanence est en fait ce
qu'il faut c'est voilà il vous faut une
bonne équipe au départ donc en est
bon je passe une heure avant ce chaque
paramètre une heure comment bien
recruter quand bien intégré chose mais
ça veut dire ça se travaille en fait et
donc mesurer quel niveau de performance
vous avez au quotidien dans ses douze
paramètre et a regardé celui sur lequel
vous devez faire un effort
le premier évidemment c'est bien recruté
vous me direz mais t'as vu on n'arrive
plus à trouver les maigres troupes lui
c'est vrai aujourd'hui je chante et
rennes ont beaucoup d'entreprises
presque tous les métiers sont les
troupes et les candidats faisaient
qu'une seule chose à faire
faites comme dans l'armée de l'air
voulait former seulement vous trouver
des gens qui sont adéquation et votre
culture c'est le principal votre culture
vos valeurs une fois que son adéquation
après vous voulez les former et puis
après c'est de la méthode à
l'intégration placés sur chaque
information vaut former ses
collaborateurs c'est évident plaisir de
chacun à 100 tonnes à l'instant t où les
gens sachent exactement ce qu'ils ont à
faire
préparation nous comptons un problème en
vol ne fois sur dix un manque de
préparation deux fois sur dix les
passionnés qui travaillent dans le
bâtiment entre un chantier bien préparé
un gentil et mal préparée
je ne raconte pas l'histoire on chantait
bien préparés tels une chance peut-être
de faire ta marge chantier mal préparée
tu es sûr de prendre le bouillon
préparation briefing c'est tous les
jours je sais pas comment on fait de
briefing mais il ya autant bref il
différent car l'entreprise
la seule chose qu'il faut regarder
c'est l'efficacité au père celle de
votre business le briefing c'est pas de
la philosophie c'est de l'action c'est
juste avant l'action pour lancer une
semaine d'activités pour lancer une
journée d'activités pour lancer un
projet beaucoup les les trois choses
qu'on travaille plus d'entreprises
d'abord c'est le langage commun ensuite
ces briefings et son correspondant le
débriefing alors le débriefing il ya
tout à faire tout à fait à nos
entreprises même les plus brillantes 1
est ce que vous avez réalisé que il a
fallu deux cent mille ans à l'humanité
pour faire son premier décollage d'un
être humain d'envoi mécaniques les plus
anciens s'en souviennent 6783 don luis
saez et pilâtre de rozier qui est n 1
avec 14 10 et les frères montgolfier je
taquine deux cent mille ans à l'homo
sapiens et au 20e siècle a fallu que 66
ans entre le premier vol des frères
wright 17 décembre 1903 notre ami neil
amstrong le 20 juillet ce sont 66 ans on
regarde l'histoire l'humanité sait rien
pourquoi pourquoi son été aussi bon bah
je veux dire l'un des secrets ont
presque le principal c'est le début et
je vous explique je parle sous contrôle
pierre henri tu fais ton premier vol de
ta vie d'un briefing en partie on ne
fera pas un tout premier vol n'a pas
décollé depuis trente secondes que ton
instructeur à côté de toi te fait un
commentaire sur la manière dont on a
tiré le manche et a gardé la kz2 la
piste 30 secondes tous les vols et à
faire un commentaire un debriefing en
vol puis tu te reposes insultant premier
vol il va te fait un débriefing générale
de l'ensemble de la mission la
préparation le briefing et le déroulé en
accéléré premier vol deuxième vol
premier vol mais c'est pas ça n'est pas
tout tous les vols de ta vie tu vas être
débriefés et même quand tu es tout seul
tu te débrouilles quand même
chez nous comme les pilotes font ça
c'est culturel les pilotes font ça du
coup les mécaniciens font ça du coup les
contrôleurs font ça en fait c'est
culturel en aéronautique tout le monde
est bref il sait ce que ça veut dire le
mot debriefing en aéronautique
un mot très simple une notion capitale
c'est la somme de tout ce que vous
imaginez derrière le mot qui pour nous
est résumé par une seule chose
et s'il ya un mot que je voudrais que
vous retenez pas seulement aujourd'hui
c'est quoi débriefing égales progrès les
briefings égales progrès et donc c'est
bien sûr en débriefant ce qui s'est pas
très bien passé ou moyens de repasser
mais également ceux qui s'est très bien
passé qui ici débrief ses succès
débriefer au succès
comprenez pourquoi vous était bon pour
bien d'en identifier les bonnes choses
pour capitaliser dessus d'abord c'est
très valorisant pour ses collaborateurs
et en même temps identifier les points
qu'il faut essayer de renouveler
débriefer au succès et débriefer le
quotidien qui est un formidable
détecteur de signaux femmes plus grand
secret d'un otx et le tibet après le
reste que du bon sens mais aussi
transmission de savoir faire qui est un
point très important notent encore on va
le prendre on est dans un bon respect du
timing
alors comment est-ce qu'on transmet
savoir-faire en or nautique comment le
capitalisme transmet en fait on n'a que
trois outils
trois outils le premier outil et de
cécile important concerne et chaque mot
est important ce qui est opérationnel
répétitif et qui a fait ses preuves
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui est
opérationnel répétitif et qui a fait ses
preuves
qu'est-ce qu'on utilise comme outil
excellent les tchékistes ce seront des
aviateurs à ma connaissance qui ont au
minimum développer des check list suite
à un crash avant la première guerre
deuxième guerre mondiale
un prototype ils ont peut-être même
inventé on est des fondus d'athlétisme
jeux partout contre le pire en riz
t'arrives à l'avion
check this inspection extérieur tu
montes dans l'avion chaque type
d'installation check list avant les
mises en route
check system peña mise en route check
list au roulage open mineurs ou des
collages en montée en paliers et même
chose retour me dire les aviateurs sont
bien sympas mais c'est un peu
psychorigide bloquer le triste figurez
vous que c'est exactement l'inversé on
aéronautique la tchëque si ce n'est pas
une contrainte c'est une libération
ça c'est une notion fondamentale vous me
dire pourquoi pourquoi dans l'entreprise
c'est pas comme ça je vais vous dire
pour parce qu'au fur et à mesure des
semaines des mois des années on en a
trop écrit en dix ans maintenant que ses
écrits vis-à-vis du chsct
je suis tranquille si l'opérateur ne
font pas c'est leur problème c'est pas
l'idée dû tourner en nautique en
arctique s'est strictement opérationnels
nous poser une question combien de
documents de checklists pierre henry
va-t-il emmenée entre new york et paris
avec tout ce que je vous ai dit que j'en
380 à votre avis combien de documents du
check list
une feuille recto verso la même que pour
un cessna un an
ces secours c'est un jeu pas la chine
standard tchéquie standard pour faire ce
vol en standard c'est une page recto
verso tension pur pour 80 tu va voler
avec patrick
c'est votre cas la liste pas un mot trop
un exemple très concret quel secteur
d'activité qui nous concerne tous et
toutes le plus tard possible dans lequel
on a un pot d jectif d'aéronautique
depuis six ans plus précisément
chirurgie et chirurgiens à ça non le
tout cas je pense toujours contrôler
vous savez qu'ils avaient plus ou moins
défilant la tête
maintenant on leur a imposé des
techniques aéronautiques depuis six ans
je prends un exemple à partir d'un
certain âge on peut un problème de
hanche
ça arrive on vous réserve une chambre la
clinique à l'hôpital la veille au soir
le matin on vient vous chercher avec un
infirmier ou un assistant avec un
chariot est votre avis quelle est la
première chose première question qui
vous plaît dans cette check-list nom
prénom date de naissance il vous emmène
ils vous emmènent il vous arrête au
milieu deuxième question qui pose c'est
quoi
nom prénom deux fois il arrive au bloc
opératoire
là les chirurgiens d'accueil et
d'infirmières bonjour monsieur bonjour
madame de l'ennemi très bien quelle est
la troisième question qui vous pose nom
prénom parfois trois fois c'est bien la
jambe droite et pas la jambe gauche
trois fois en fois ci bien la hanche ce
n'est pas le gros orteil trois fois ce
n'est pas allergique aux produits quand
vous donnez pour s'endormir et là on
vous endort peut plus rien faire vous au
père et à l'issue de l'intervention
crédit la check list nom prénom c'est un
peu tard monsieur
f rosa question les outils en compte les
outils toute attaque table entre outils
super qu'est ce qu'on regarde en
deuxième et compresse avancée des
paquets en vrac maintenance et des
paquets de 10 alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
on comptait compresse 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
zut il en manque une qu'est ce qu'on
fait excellent on recompte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 buts il en manque une qu'est ce
qu'on fait on voit pas à la faute pour
opérer par monsieur là on cherche on
cherche par terre on chez alain poubelle
on cherche sous les chaussures et se
retrouve pas qu'est ce qu'on fait
je te dis si on est pas con quand même
fait faire on ne referme pas tant qu'on
n'a pas trouvé 10e est ce que vous
connaissez la mi les résultats de la
mise en place de cette procédure de
check list pour des bac + 12 depuis six
ans en france 30 % d'erreurs médicales
en moins 50% de morbidité en moins pour
certaines maladies nosocomiales ça
s'appelle un bloc opératoire et check
list ça marche ça marche pour les bac +
12 ça marche pour les banques -3 ça
marche pour tout le monde mais
l'intelligence date check list un mot
trop premier outil deuxième outil et
esso prise standard open procédure
c'est-à-dire tout savoir faire chez nous
on l'écrit manuel de vol cohérent
réalise et cessna ou hier 400 reçoit un
bouquin manuel de vol mais qu'il écrit
il ya 40 ans il ya plus de ce monde mais
c'est comme ça qu'on transmet savoir
faire c'est vrai pour les pilotes
mécaniciens un contrôleur elle trouve un
outil sa formation et axa compte aller
sur la lune
des check list pour ce qui est aux
persiennes répétitif des sottises et la
formation
ça c'est un point très important
lorsqu'en plus en en culture latine on
est très attiré par ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné donc débrief sur ce qui n'a
pas marché ça c'est courant mon
entreprise mais voir les clés de succès
pour quoi on a réussi je le vois moi
beaucoup développement commercial c'est
rare il ment parce qu'on est obsédé par
des la plus jeune âge à la mauvaise note
on arrive peut-être a eu cinq là dessus
j'ai eu 18 là on s'en fout c'est dommage
comment t'as fait voir à 18 donc ça
aussi une entreprise
moi je le vois très très bon
je pense qu'on poursuive pas ce que vous
pourrez écouter patrie pendant des
heures tout cas ça donne vraiment envie
je aller dans des dimensions plus un peu
plus personnel c'est que tout à l'heure
on l'a dit là on a compris la sélection
la difficulté l'envi de le faire ça tu
fais ça tu es venu tout non un peu par
hasard toujours moi c'est un peu le
hasard
et quand j'étais commence kadri sur
mirage 2000 à dijon il n'y a pas de
coups qui vient on à un fait la mise en
service du mirage 2000 en 84 et là je
vois la démonstration de la patrouille
moi j'ai jamais pensé en fait
et puis je croise un copain qui était
rentré à patrick deux ans avant jeudi et
tiassalé marco ça va se passe bien pim
dit beaucoup de femmes la marge brute
s'est pas eu jeudi comment on fait bon
train pas trouvé il me faut dire très
fort bombe avant jeudi serait fort je
suis entré en fait voilà donc donc c'est
comme ça que je suis entré en fait il ya
deux types de recrutement atteint tu
peux revenir avant le soft est équipier
donc c'est atroce bac + 1 à bac +5 ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on fait l'école de
l'air ils sont forcément futur leader
donc on passe quand on est recruté
confiture leader on passe une année de
charognards en numéro 2 et puis fin 2004
et l'année suivante au pastis heures si
tu vois bien comment ça se passe alors
là on dimension plus terre à terre
puisque l'on parle de d'optimisation
débriefer puis il ya quand même des
sommes en jeu parce que pour se donner
des ordres de grandeur un avion de
chasse c'est quelle quelle grandeur à
ces 100 millions d'euros enfin c'est pas
il ya aussi une vision utilitaire à
falun ça ça dépend les options si tu
prends les essuie glaces ou pas du
glaçon fait corps alors je citerai pas
de constructeur automobile il y en a
dans la salle donc attention aux options
mais voilà il ya aussi des enjeux
tout simplement budgétaire aussi donc
doudou la viser l'excellence et puis bon
évidemment les vies humaines
ça c'est clair et aussi des sacrées en
jeu alors toujours dans les questions là
on parle de la patrouille de france donc
tu as dit très fort presque par hasard
que tu voulais intégrer la patrouille
est le premier vol alors tout à l'heure
ça se passe derrière
mais quand tu es devant quand tu
commences à piloter réellement que
quelle émotion ça génère sa piteuse
généré j'ai plutôt vu remporter mon
premier vol en leader en faites pas ce
que je raconte une anecdote quand on est
à l'école de l'air comme le fils de
madame quand vous apprenez des buffets
des premiers vols en 3e année ou en 4ème
année ça dépend des promotions à
l'époque on voulait sur fouga magister
et puis dont vous avez deux trois vols
puis vous arrivez vous de parachute
comme ça a commenté le premier vol tout
ça n'est vraiment pas très à l'aise avec
un instructeur vous faites le tour
l'avion vous installez tac
et puis les mettre en route et après il
ya un gros moment une fougueuse effet
tous les procédures s'est appelé la tour
de contrôle là vous avez des trous y ai
la trouille parce que te dire vous savez
pas trop dire l'or au début vous dit
salon tour ici verglas 42
je suis au parking d'automation de
maison votre corps donc frémissent et
puis là si vous êtes à l'horaire la
patrouille son vol de midi pour
l'entraînement verticale son deuxième de
la journée
donc là où vous êtes vous et et
résidents et là vous entendez tout d'un
coup sur la même fréquence
pato jack 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 leader voilà là
c'est sérieux là mais je veux dire c'est
qu'elle mec en l'espace de trois
secondes
ces huit personnes qu'on parlait et un
message est passé et vous vous êtes là
bonjour à tour si un machin vous
d'accord et donc ça ça vous impressionne
en fait
et donc ce leader la première fois où
j'étais 10 heures donc j'ai pensé à le
petit bdf pilote que j'étais dix ans
avant et donc quand j'ai dit que ma voix
la plus mal possible et de la première
fois j'étais du jury
atos tchèque très rock layher est là
dans celui leaders civils et il y avait
dix années d'expérience et un outil qui
passait dans ma tête en dix ans et
leader d'un petit coin donc c'est ça ça
m'avait marqué et puis après vous êtes
concentré ce que vous avez à faire là tu
viens d'abord des deux une fierté en
tout cas j'ai vu tout à l'heure que tu
abordes une décoration semble-t-il
quelque chose aussi tu es tu peux en
parler
non monsieur monsieur c'est normal en
fait au bout d'un set attend vous êtes
légion d'honneur
non en fait nous c'est presque dans le
paquetage d'officiers quand on fait une
carrière que
normal qu'au bout d'un moment vous avez
décoration que c'est ça ta plus grande
fierté ou tu trouves d'autres aliments
dits décorations we ou autour du tout
décoration super invention de notre miss
napoléon
les gens sont très attachés non c'est
très bien si tu sais tout c'est toujours
sympa mais mais on peut personne je
pense ne travaille pour ses décorations
non la plus grande fierté non c'est de
rassembler des hommes derrière un
objectif donner du sens servi en fait
servir la nation à 6 une chose que vous
dire en fait moi je suis très fier que
mon pays soit le pays des droits de
l'homme
je suis super fier et je serai encore
plus fier si on rentrait maintenant dans
la constitution les devoirs de l'homme
et il n'a pas trente-six de devoir il ya
un devoir que devraient rentrer c'est le
respect aspects des autres respect de la
liberté des autres respect de la
circulation des autres respect de
l'opinion des autres respect de ses
parents respect des enseignants voilà ce
qui manque dans ce pays c'est le respect
[Applaudissements]
non plus qu'en ce moment c'est compliqué
parfois circulé alors là des dimensions
plus personnel aussi donc des souvenirs
la dimension personnelle
est ce qu'il ya un meilleur souvenir
quelque chose qui sort du lot qui te
vient spontanément quand tu y penses
on a la chance en aéronautique mais ça
c'est vrai pour les aviateurs ton
premier vol on a plein de vous savez moi
je termine beaucoup l'entreprise moi je
crois que j'observe à tout est
intéressant mais en fait c'est tout le
monde le coeur que vous mettez dans
chaque chose en fait un sourire de
quelqu'un et que fait la gueule tout le
temps le jour où fin sourire et ben
c'est un super plaisir
tous les jours le fait de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
observez bien ans en russie pour les
gens qui s'ouvre on s'enrichit de tout
contact de toute heure de tout ce qu'on
observe à regarder on se connaissait pas
que vous vouliez vous vouliez pas votre
cher patrick il est rentré dans votre
galaxy une demi heure vous la mettrais
au fin fond de la galaxie peut-être mais
dans votre excellent internat de
personnel vous aurez eu cet échange avec
françois et moi et moi c'est pareil moi
je vous connaissais pas jean faisait
aucun et bien aujourd'hui vous françois
un peu plus et vous incite site est donc
ce que veut dire c'est que on s'enrichit
des autres en fait passer la clé du des
clés du bonheur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment
créé une vibration positif parce qu'il
suffit de regarder extérieur crois que
c'est une journée qui est belle et qu'on
va vraiment retenir alors ça se passe
bien c'est merveilleux des fois ça se
passe moins bien
alors est-ce que tu as un souvenir
particulier qui t'a marqué un peu plus
une ombre au tableau
parce que ça permet si les choses on est
difficile de bassy moi c'est chaque fois
que j'ai mis ma chemise blanche et noire
le type qu'on dit que ma chemise blanche
lorsqu on enterre un camarade
donc je vais malheureusement
quelques-uns début des années 70 est
beaucoup d'accidents moi quand j'ai
vraiment commencé à piloter fin des
années 70 80
alors on en a eu beaucoup mon meilleur
comme j'ai perdu mes deux meilleurs
copains bruno et jean marc donc ça s'est
jamais drôle en fait mais bon après faut
une philosophie sur la vie
ça jamais drôle les familles tout ce
qu'on reste avec eux deux des années
donc il vous manque mais comme tous les
êtres chers que j'ai entre eux ou
perdent en fait donc saluer souvenir
parce que tout à l'heure tu nous as
souvent j'ai entendu plusieurs reprises
le mot hasard comme si tu étais là alors
je pose la question de savoir si le
hasard est ce que ça existe n'existe pas
est ce que le fait mais voilà corps et
non non non moi je rêvais nom de grange
était à moitié breton donc les deux
montagnes donc je vais faire du ski et
elle est la mère donc non l'aviation
fait rentrez pas chez nous il ya pas
militaire pain aviateurs mais après j'ai
adoré ce métier j'ai une chance mener
tous partis dans une deuxième expérience
de vie ce qu'il faut ça vit le mieux
possible ce tronçon en accord avec
soi-même en fait quand je termine
entreprises genre demandent l'alignement
mais je parle la vision des valeurs des
finalités des principes d'action des
modes modes de travail et de l'adn et
dans tout groupe humain ça a tendance à
se déshabiller et donc l'idée c'est
qu'on se réaligne c'est le rôle de tous
les managers sa de vérifier qu'on parte
pas dans tous les sens sont les
principes de ce travail il faut pas que
ces dérives sinon ça sera pas bien c'est
pareil pour chacun d'entre nous en fait
c'est très digne et que soi même et ça
c'est le plus dur en fait est
parfaitement en phase avec qui on est en
fait non pas cindy à faire ça il me
semble est donc là c'est toute une vie
forte consacrée à l'aviation sinon ça
aurait pu être quoi être quand j'avais
10 ans jouait le prêtre donc donc que je
l'ait pas fait mais la tutelle du cilss
un médecin non mais je suis très très
dans les armes et non mon père était
médecin de campagne je trouve c'est un
des plus beaux mais dit qu'ils soient le
médecin parce que vous sillonnez les
gens donc voilà donc ça c'est un des
plus beaux et j'ai pu faire ça à la fin
de la guerre du pilote j'aurais fait
métier que je fais une sorte de médecine
ne pas glisser une traditionnelle donc
maintenant que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour le médical belge
persuadé que quand tu interviens de
l'entreprise tu fait beaucoup de bien
aux gens et beaucoup de bien aux
entreprises et vraiment je vous propose
de d'applaudir patrick et au point
pourtant si vous le voulez bien il nous
reste quelques minutes si quelqu'un à
part pierre-henri parce qu'il a été sur
le devant de la scène
est ce qu'il y aurait une question pipe
gérard defrance
une wii il ya c'était qu'en 2011 je
crois déjà 6 7 ans 1
virginie virginie guilhaume est
absolument c'est une femme on est très
heureux c'est la première fois que
d'abord une douzaine de femmes pilotes
de chasse dans la madeleine
je suis à peu près 150 pilotes
opérationnel mais c'est ouvrir avant
c'était fermé maintenant c'est très
ouvert
et la deuxième chose c'est que virginie
c'est la première femme leader mais non
seulement de la patrouille de france
mais des patrouilles acrobatiques
mondial c'est à dire qu'il n'a jamais
vue dans l'histoire de l'aéronautique
une femme leader de pasqua chromatique
nationale et c'était le cas de virginie
méfaits super on sait comment elle fait
beaucoup de confrères d'autres questions
pour terminer le lieu le mieux les
licences
le choix est ce que les personnes sont
des bruits départ
mais ce que je pêche est ce que leur
place par exemple
demont sein de la patrouille et de s
aussi leur personnalité ou est ce que
c'est
non
alors d'abord il ya une notion très
importante on parlait tout à l'heure à
table l'entreprise libéré en
aéronautique par exemple la fonction
prime le grade hier chez nous un
lieutenant peu désordre général ne pose
aucun problème en une préparation de vol
dans un briefing pour une réalisation en
vol parce que les lieutenants étaient
définies comment comment est ce que
pendant le comice quadrillée comme chef
de patrouille général et abonnés il vole
moins souvent donc et rhin et pendant le
débriefing c'est le général keith mother
de lieutenant bon faut pas en abuser pas
ce cas par an mais les choses dans
l'ordre
d'accord mais voilà fonction prime le
grade dans l'action par exemple d'accord
ensuite à la patrouille c'est simple on
a deux équipiers un futur leader le
futur l'idée on est tous en charnière et
après obasi d'heures donc quand vous
rentrez pas tout vous savez déjà si vous
êtes futur leader ou pas et ensuite dans
la carrière de d'équipier la patrouille
soit vous faites
intérieur extérieur extérieur soit vous
faites intérieur second solo leader solo
et en 4ème année où fait remplaçant en
passant chez nous c'est le plus ancien
des patrouilles plan peser tout le monde
sauf les leurs comment ça se passe les
bonnes questions
1ère question pour catherine petit nom
opérationnel puisque à la tradition des
petits noms là il ya du vécu déjà les
deux vécu ouais pendant la guerre du
golfe et michael à noailles et cause de
l'archange et
oui il ya sur des jeux de mots soit par
rapport à votre nom soit on a toujours
des mots courts
pourquoi parce qu'on en opération en
combat comme ça il faut aller très très
vite
non pas dire un mot lieutenant patrick
que ces deux noms ont dit mike tu tourne
à gauche puis tourner à droite ou devant
des choses comme ça très rapidement et
donc on a tous un nom de guerre en fait
ce qu'on appelle un nom de guerre qui
est choisi par les copains où je sais
vous même dépend des circonstances que
si derrière petite question est ce qui
est déjà eu des accidents graves
ça n'a pas toujours pas trouvé un
combatif parlant le patrouille
américaine vient de perdre deux pilotes
dans deux ans l'us air force donc
évidemment on prend des risques qu'on
essaie de mesurer évidemment on joue
avec les limites donc il faut faire très
attention il est parfois les
impondérables et la patrouille allait
elle fait partie des pages sera comme
dit que le moins d'accidents belle en a
quand même en moyenne une tous les 12
ans ou 11 ans morte elle est là ça fait
dernier ses 2000 2001 chez plus de
millage coin donc de ça fait 19 ans qui
appliquent sans mental de 4 9 ans une
dernière question parce que nous sommes
là pour respecter les animaux si nous
prenons le dessert debout à côté on va
pouvoir continuer mais bien sûr soit par
l'effort ou laurent va devenir est ce
que c'est vrai que y en a plus de
combats aériens aujourd'hui donnent les
armes
oui c'est pas faux en fait les derniers
vraiment combats aériens sont en guerre
du golfe un petit peu en ex yougoslavie
parce que il maison il n'y a pas
vraiment de combat ils ont décollé il
est intéressant poser rapidement parce
qu'il y avait de vrais supporteurs haine
de l'occident
effectivement de combat festou fait ce
qu'on dit en face à face en fait il n'a
pas lu mersa seraient toujours pauvres
parce que c'est on sait pas de quoi
demain est fait en fait si on se fâche
fortement et que les russes ou avec nos
doigts etc les turcs et d'autres pays
ça va très vite l'autre jour d'ailleurs
il ya un turc qui a descendu un avion
russe
ce qui est égal à d'ailleurs c'est
presque un assassinat pour moi ce qu'il
a fait le mec tu es derrière en train de
tourner en train de 2,1 et puis il a
empiété très légèrement sur la bordure
savez les frontières conduite en vol
c'est pas marqué un et pas un grand
trait rouge et donc et donc il a
légèrement vers shooter de deux rôles
tic et l'autre étaient pleines arrière
et leurs familles s'il ça c'est pas cool
du tout mais il est donc voyez donc ça
peut très vite des diverger mais c'est
vrai le combat aérien festou fesses
comme ça il y en a en ce moment assez
peu et il n'a plus depuis depuis
quasiment la guerre du golfe une
dernière question de thierry mais on
parle d'accident
j'ai toujours en tête que lorsqu'on est
temps d'un avion de s'éjecter
oui j'imagine vous êtes en patrouille
vous touchez la viande à côté vous
n'avez pas le temps vous éjecter ça
dépend ça dépend de la hauteur
d'habitude on fait beaucoup de choses en
certaine altitude tout ça vous enterrez
pas trop les avions passé parce qu'on
est en haute altitude mais la patrouille
en est très très bas donc si un
accrochage en basse altitude ya une
chance sur deux que le mec se crashe
donc c'est pour ça dans certains cas pas
s'éjecter mon copain bruno gaillard
qu'on a perdus a perdu il est un pilote
d'essai soit badiane de cazaux est un
exercice lui bernard bruno et bernabé
s'appelle bernard aussi quittant bernard
abrash qui était devant et en fait ils
ont un dévissage du moteur c'est un
mirage iii b sur l'île sont éjectés mais
le problème c'est que le cg ctam n'était
pas 0-0 à dire que si vous avez une
vitesse descendante comme ça même celles
à 0 0 vous ai pas le temps d'ouvrir le
patch et anglaise ouvrir d'accord donc
en fait chaque s'éjecta bla son domaine
de vol à l'époque sur mirage f1 des
premiers vols même / / / alphajet
d'ailleurs il faut les minimum 160
kilomètres heure la vitesse à vitesse
verticale nul donc au décollage si vous
aviez bon si je m'éjecte et à 130
kilomètres heure je me crachait
175 j'avais une chance de le parachute
s'ouvre avant que je touche au sol et
avant non d'accord mais non on a des 0 0
donc ça veut dire que si vous mettez en
route avec votre chasseur sur le parking
si un feu de moteur v bloqué vite sortir
pouvez vous éjecter au sol si vous avez
même ac100 aussi d une forte vitesse de
chute mais pas ça dépend ça se calcule
en fait c'est pas sûr que ça marche
donc voilà comment ça se passe on
[Applaudissements]